the glass lab started in 1986 at least
the glass lab as we know it today that's
when I started at MIT a professor and
the material science department
approached me and said I have a lab and
building 4 would you'd like it
and not knowing what was in it I just
said yes and thinking that I was going
to turn it into a research lab but
before I had a chance to even visit the
lab I was approached by two students and
a glass artist from outside of the
mighty to use the glass furnace in the
lab that had been there I hadn't been
used in many years but they wanted to
turn it on and I didn't know what
glassblowing was so I learned with great
difficulty how to blow glass and at the
same time I approached the School of
Engineering for funding to do the
renovation in the laboratory to turn it
into a hot job that was at a time when
MIT was particularly concerned about
innovation and teaching innovation
across the campus and the pitch became
this is a way that students can learn to
improvise together it's one of the few
craft arts that you have to work in a
team and one thing led to another we
began teaching first and I ap course and
seminar
and soon it became the most
oversubscribed class at MIT yeah so I've
heard about it and I entered in the
lottery of over ivy
Mary and I didn't get it
but I really wanted to take a
sign up for the lottery again and this
it's such an amazing opportunity I've
been really interested in glassblowing I
knew that
I definitely want to take one possible
future
want to take a couple for couple more
beginner classes that
the glass lab is a place at MIT where
people can come and use their hands to
do things and it's one of the few places
where you can go and build things and
learn about things that are part of the
curriculum in some way but learn about
it the way your hand and body picks it
up instead of strictly intellectually we
encourage a lot of cross-disciplinary
play in the lab that's the thing that
we're the biggest amount of juice comes
out in my experience when students make
connections between using the material
and things that they're learning in
other situations the glass lab draws
people from all over the institute in
fact it's designed that way it's
non-credit activity we've always
believed if we offer credit then only
certain majors will be able to take
advantage of the facility so we've kept
credit out of the picture primarily
because it's so important for students
to MIT to meet people from other places
at the Institute and not only meet them
an example of something unique that's
come out of the glass lab is a glass
band that's come out this past the
beginner in the glassblowing program I
think I was really excited to get more
involved and music was something that
was very important to me at the time I
didn't playing flute for ten years at
that point so I thought it'd be really
exciting to delve into this project with
them at the same time though being MIT I
felt like we could push it towards
something a little bit more exciting you
know you can order a glass of flute
online so I thought it'd be much more
interesting you know if we take
advantage of the creative environment
and start working with more experimental
designs both kind of experimenting with
the mechanics and the material
interaction with the voice of the
instruments a festered or well position
say incubated for a couple of years and
then approaching evidence' for i'm the
music department about the idea what if
we have this cross-disciplinary class
where we get people from music
department we get somebody who's
interested in composing or helping us
put sounds together so that we could
perform maybe but let's find out what
kinds of sounds glass makes and and make
something happen with that so that's how
this got started but this was a student
inspired course if you really think
about it it wasn't a faculty member
driving this it was a student driving
this and that's the kind of thing that
can happen in a facility like the glass
lab it's the reason why we have these
things in MIT now after 20 over 25 years
of doing it we've seen just the impact
that that's had on graduates they look
back on the glass lab experience at MIT
as some of the most important activities
that they've done primarily because a
few they met and who they've worked with
most do not become glass artists when
they take this course but they have an
experience trying to improvise with
people of all different types of
backgrounds and capabilities and that's
good because everybody is learning as we
do these fifties